italy is not here unfortunately i know
that
yeah okay so people joining this we
are talking about array operations in
modern language particularly
heading into version 12.2 um
all right so we're going to look at
array reduce first
and then i want to remind people that
we had a variety of mechanisms here that
we discussed last time
and i want to go through those
mechanisms and make sure that we are
on track to do things with them okay so
i'm going to remind everybody
i hope um
all right let's take a look at this um
okay so
um there are different
versions of this broadcasting type
operation
i want to remind people of this okay
do people remember this yeah
yeah i mean i think some people were not
there probably in pto so
the reminder can be useful as well okay
okay so there are three versions
headdress infix explicit and i guess
there's also
this idea of level applied
okay so
let's let's look at let's look first at
level applied because it's fairly
straightforward i think
it's just take this function this is a
headdress take this function
and apply it at level n
well people understand this this is a
very basic question how is this
different from map
because it is
so it is doing things like
um column application in an array
okay what do i mean by that i think what
i mean by that it is doing
um so okay
so let's take a look here well i guess
column application is useful but i think
level specs don't get you columns really
well then maybe level applied isn't
right but but as a
okay so let's take a look here we have
array a
3 4 for example okay now what we want to
do
is we want to apply this at level 2
and maybe level applied isn't the right
term but what we want this to do
is an operation that is the equivalent
and i think jose
um had identified this it's a you know
it's a transpose
apply um uh
transpose back type operation
are we making sense yeah that's what is
it
sorry go ahead yeah that's what reduce
does but that's the headdress
version of this right yes that's correct
so this is hold on let me let me just
write this out here
but also by the way it looks at least in
the array reducing
documentation looks like it's actually a
map not apply because it's
look it's a it's running mean of list of
such and such instead of just mean of
the numbers which would be what apply
does
good point except that we have a family
of things like curry applied and so on
so we have to think about how that works
um well we could call it level mapped
okay so let's let's let's understand
here so
this is applying
at a level okay so there's
there's the headdress form
and there is the explicit form
and the explicit form is array
reduced is that correct
yes yes
okay okay so there's a pl that's
applying it a level
the other version is auto replicating
auto replicating slash
slash generalized listable
right and for that we also have
three forms okay there we have also an
infects
form okay am i making sense
yeah i mean possibly i'm not sure if we
want to
implement all versions for every
operation
i think we do in this in this case right
because this is
the infix form we talked about at length
right
the infix form is an
insertion at a certain level and i think
you've got design specs for that right
etienne or the for the insertion
yes so it's this basically right
yeah which is yeah yeah
uh well i'm not convinced that this
makes sense
but have you looked at it in detail
yes and i don't think it makes sense
okay
well and what is your alternative
suggestion
um
so i'm gonna make a comment about it
okay you are right that it has weird
features
just like listable has listability has
weird features
but listability the weird features are
definitely useful
this will have weird features this isn't
associative for example
plus isn't associative anymore with this
right
right uh yeah well i'm not sure why rob
isn't here
but well i guess we should get dropped
out but oh okay
okay well anyway maybe maybe better to
do something like
you know in some languages like in
haskell for example for
um like combining arrays they use plus
plus
as an infix so i mean maybe it'd be
safer to do something like that than to
have
another you know to use just the normal
plus because that's kind of weird well
it's an interesting idea that we could
use
you know if we think there are two cases
that are the most interesting
um the um
the um like the two conventions
one and minus one about the level yeah
right right right right right question
mark
if there are primarily
two relevant level conventions
and the operation we want is basically
plus
and the main operation is plus
perhaps introduced another plus well
actually so
that that's an interesting idea although
that's not what i was saying i was just
saying that the
you know if if part of it is you know
concern is overloading single plus
because single plus
you know and even stuff like
associativity you know it's like
you'd kind of like to have that um
you know and so if you're overloading it
for this insertion thing it might be
kind of weird because i don't
i can't think of any other places where
you really overload plus for something
like this
well i agree but so so one question is
is it in fact the case that the only
operation we care about in session with
is plus
because if that's true you might be
absolutely right that the best thing to
do
go ahead times minus i mean all
all element wise operation no
not all not all there are many many many
element-wise operations
right i mean look
the fact is that that we can also
imagine
a you know there could be there's a
there's a headdress form right a level
padded
you know if you don't if you want this
for some obscure operation right you can
say
level padded circle plus whatever it is
right you see what i'm saying
yeah yeah i mean i think i mean
at times uh i don't know maybe maybe
jerome
and mateo can give more examples i guess
so i guess i should clarify that if
i mean i suppose the two argument
insertion
where you you know are explicit so that
the insertion evaluates
first basically you know that makes
sense but
should the one argument form where one
argument
audio
jerome can you mute
um
okay in any case um all right what was
the one argument form you were talking
about
where it sort of auto magically guesses
what it is what do you mean
uh there's a question of what
level look there's a question of where
the scalar level is
do you understand what i'm saying
right remember that yeah yeah we talked
about that i think this was not
the big issue but i think what uh it is
referring to is uncertain with only one
argument
and and that automatically find which
level to insert
and this i agree doesn't make sense i
think we never advocated for that
um like like the one argument would have
a default
which is probably the opposite of what
yes exactly that's the whole point
that's what we want to do this thing
here is the equivalent
is opposite to listability
to the to the listability default right
and this is what i argue
doesn't make sense okay well i don't
understand that
okay explain why because
uh you know because
no why well let me if you let me finish
a sentence
please so
right because you know we have listable
functions we have functions which are
not listable but
act listably you know uh
the it's you know the
uh and maybe there are times when you
don't want this to fire like okay so
that i uh so hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on so the question is
should this work like um
you know like for example nothing on
splice work
okay so nothing and splice are purely
working inside particular functions
right making sense
so one possibility is that this
construct only works with particular
functions like the arithmetic functions
did you understand what i'm saying so
the one argument form or one argument
form
would only probably be a different name
i don't know how it would work there but
the basic idea would be
it's only supported in the arithmetic
operations
because you only care about the one
argument form in the case where your
function
okay so if the function
is explicitly given right
eg i e f of x y
rather than x plus y
then you might as well use a headdress
does that make sense
agreed well except i i don't know
exactly how that then
works because then the whole point is
you're wrapping
in this case your
i see this is saying pad everything
until it gets to be consistent right
that's what
that means i.e pad all arguments
to make them consistent i would say
replicate like paddings just that you
have zeros or constant values but
okay
well okay so level replicated i guess i
guess it's padding not in the sense that
it's padding the array but in the sense
that it's padding
like if you run dimensions on it it's
padding the dimensions part yeah
right i.e
padding dimensions though not
padding elements the replicating
elements
right okay so
this is for um
uh let's see freeman is arc how does
this deal with an arbitrary number of
arguments i think this is not a problem
because
what this will do is any number of
arguments they'll all get replicated up
to be i mean this probably would have
if we say level replicated i don't
really like the name
it's level padded it's padding the
levels right it would be circle plus
and then something about
lev padded and then something about
which arguments are
going to be padded right would be the
general form
and then this then goes and just does
its thing
now an alternative might be
to put a signal on the arguments to say
this pads up
right so the alternative is that you
have the outer function
and an argument is saying i want to be
padded up
to be consistent throughout this
throughout this function so to speak
right then
go ahead sorry the i i think this this
looks more usable because you are
oh no no no no no no yeah no you haven't
been listening
right the the the whole point is the
whole point
is that's not going to work in general
because many functions don't have that
simple form only the arithmetic
functions easily do that
right so of course it's more usable for
the arithmetic functions
right but that's not the only case we're
dealing with do you understand
yeah okay but it just can fail if
if our function is not supported so no
no no no no
no no no if you deal with something like
nothing for instance okay if i say
if i say a nothing b right
that's a list it works if i say f a
nothing b it's dumb as a stone it does
nothing
nothing does nothing so to speak to get
it
okay same with splice right so that will
be the pattern for this
right so then you can treat it
symbolically except in functions that
happen to deal with it
but would be a well-defined set of
functions
by the way jerome has a bad connection
but he gave me a list of functions that
we use in threading layer i think so
time
subtract divide plus power
uh and then we also have min max mod
subtract say it again so time subtract
divide
plus okay the classic uh
simple arithmetic thing and then power
min max but but you know these are not
very obvious what to do with them
because
what what you're saying is
you're saying for example that that you
want to be able to do
something like this you know six
this thing here right
you want to be able to say yeah i'm not
sure if it's this thing no no no no no
no
so so so right so so in this case
listability would is what you want to be
able to do is something like this you
want to be able to say you know
dot power whatever it is um and then
uh you want to be able to say abc right
is that right or do you want to is it
the other way around
no in in standardless stability right
you can do
this a b
right that works but what you want to be
able to do is this case as well
exactly right okay
you can also add all logical and
comparison operators to that list
which are not currently uh listable
which aren't listable right
so those are those are these are
non-listable
but it's something that would be nice to
have uh
mister we have the vector versions of
less and greater
yeah right which so in in that case
vector
vector less of what is it how does it
work
six seven one uh one eight
for example no what is that supposed to
be okay but this is one result no
no no no wait wait how is this supposed
to work it
you give it a list of things
right so that would have been a one
argument
because the second argument is uh
is a comparison all right so this is
doing something completely different
no it's not yes it is it's asking you
whether any of these things
which vector is you know whether any of
these is less
isn't it
yeah i think we're talking about
different things yeah this is just
comparing two vectors
whereas what you want is something
where you get true false you know a list
true false for each element
that is you know and where you can say
bool of that and so on
right exactly when you get an array a
sort of mask array mask type thing
which is something we use yeah
okay um whoever's got bad connections
should
put themselves on mute please
the okay in any case um
all right so so one of the ideas here is
i mean this is clearly what the kind of
thing we want
but it has issues as the stability has
with associativity and other such things
so
you know a very convenient thing would
be if there was
some kind of operator modifying
you know notation that we could use
but i think that still doesn't help us
because if we've got a three argument
plus and one of those arguments one of
those is the i mean
what would happen let's imagine that we
had something like um
uh you know if we say uh one thing
a plus well here i need to write it out
more explicitly but i mean
something like this and then we say
you know this is our dot plus or
whatever it is
and then this which which by the way
isn't a isn't allowable syntax
um and then and then we have another one
here which is an ordinary plus so i
don't know insertion
a b for example i mean in other words
we it's very unclear what this means
in other words it has to look around no
actually that's a bad example here
let's just do abc here see what i'm
saying
so it's not clear which way round you do
this and it matters
is this making sense to people yes
so um
you know the question is
for example if you want if you had two
insertions
in here what would it do in other words
in
in this case here i mean it gets kind of
quite messy because
in this case let's say we had another
insertion of the same form
right presumably that just
is the equivalent of one two three plus
abc inside that insertion it's like you
collect the insertions first
but it's not obvious what happens if
that insertion has
for example this in it which would
require another level
of replication
actually i'm not even sure if this is if
this is conformable at all
that's a another topic by the way
um that would be nice to have not just
new level and set it but also level of
dimension one which you have here
that i kind of promoted to dimension
that is needed
well explain that to me i mean so so
isn't it
time one right what you did is a array
three time one
yeah and if you look very on the left
which is
uh two times three uh oh yeah so two
times three oh no this one won't be
confirmable okay okay
but let's say you have you know three
time one and we had a three time two
uh then you could promote the one to be
a two
there's no new level and set it but you
just duplicated
and and this works as well and um
i don't quite understand that but but
look so so i mean what you're saying is
this level padded thing we probably
should work out how that works
right because that's the general that's
that's the more controlled case of this
getting an infects form is is derivative
on that
does that make sense i would agree with
that statement
yeah um
so yeah so let's go figure out how this
thing should work now
the explicit version of this oh that's a
ray replicate as opposed to the explicit
form here which is array reduce
okay do we understand how array
replicate would work
that basically takes an array array
replicate
simply takes an array takes an array
and gives the final dimensions
and then has to probably say where it
inserts
the replications is that true or does it
know that it does
need to know and i think i think we came
up with some syntax for this last time
um okay well here we go and after dims
here we go yes
if you scroll down if you scroll down
you probably see them
yeah i think we actually had oh yeah you
go yeah you have a list of rules
somewhere right rubricated area
insert after you have a little comment
okay so fine so could we get a mock-up
of replicated array please could
somebody make that
right okay that would be nice to specify
somebody because
uh i mean i'm happy to do some some
things but it's not our core
expertise let's say well we've got the
wrong people in this meeting then
i mean i think you guys should make a
version of this
okay and and then okay then we can do a
top-level version you know
yeah exactly and if it's really going to
be burnt into some low-level code
maybe that's something we can use modern
compiler technology for maybe zepignu
can work on it
but let's first of all get the design
handle which is not very difficult
you know to see in top level code
okay so this is um let's see what the
the syntax here would be before dims and
after dimms right so
um that will be that form
and then there's the before dims
after dims okay and that's the thing
that
once it's been done this way after
replication
pure listability should work
is that a true statement
right is this always true
well i think this is all correctly yes
yeah i think i think it is always true
because the stability goes from the top
this is an advantage of listability
going from the top
did you understand what i'm saying
do you understand what i'm saying i
don't understand what you mean
why listen okay what i mean by that is
listability
whereas the alternative convention for
insertion
looks at the lowest level like this
insertion one two three would go in
and insert in the lowest level the
stability starts from the top
so so long as these things are
conformant at the top
the stability should work right and
array replicate
will make them conformant at the top
they may have lower level pieces that
are not conformal but that's not
relevant
it will evaluate to just an array right
replicate so then all the rules for
regular arrays work so
i know that but but what's not obvious
is that if you've got
the let's say you've got something which
you were going to do with insertion
right the whole point is you could
explicitly array replicate
insertion okay if insertion knew its
environment
insertion is equivalent to array
replicate
do you understand what i'm saying
insertion is a shortcut
where you're not specifying the
environment inside the insertion
yep yes right okay so what i'm claiming
is
that were you to replace insertion with
an explicit array replicate
that then the operations plus times
whatever they are
would work correctly with respect to
just by listability
that's my claimed theorem and that
should be checked
do people understand what i'm what i'm
claiming
i believe that to be true okay
now obviously there are some exceptions
like the less greater thing because they
aren't listable
am i making sense i mean it's not
obvious to me that we
you know we should study the question of
making less and greater lustable
i mean right now it's just an error
actually doesn't evaluate i think
yeah i know i know i know i know right i
think there have been a number of times
when i've wanted to use them listably
i mean i think that probably should
evaluate let's i mean let's
let's let's ask can somebody send out a
piece of mail
generally i think the problem here would
be equal
so these functions are tightly operated
i see
i see i see i see i see
yeah that clearly cannot be listable
oh maybe i mean that's another thing
though where it would be
where it would be nice to have like
there are times when you do want to be
listable and there are times when you
don't
right so maybe i'm trying to think if
there's some existing
thing that kind of does this but it
might be nice if there was kind of a
headdress that you could put
you know that basically just says make
this listable i mean of course you can
use function
but it's a little bit well okay so
that's what is the quest question of a
question
yeah there's thread yes okay but does
thread work
if i say i don't think not necessarily
for higher levels
but also what about um uh
okay so this would be something where
you would say
listably equal
abcd but so now this though
right because you could just do listably
but another version you could do
would be at level x which is kind of
similar to what you're talking about
before
yes which seems a bit like map thread if
you can give it like a level spec right
right right so this is similar to level
applied
equal comma 1 a b
c d so that's suggesting that
the um the default
um
yeah go ahead well i mean this is a map
thread actually i just looked at map
thread does actually take a level spec
which basically does this
um so it's you know did you understand
since it's like a
thread of yeah i mean but that because
it's not a headdress form it's map
thread
into map thread of equal
onto abcd
at level i mean at level well let's just
do an f here
um okay that's that
right
but map thread does map thread have a
have a head
have a um an operator form no
i don't think so yeah i
did there you go
okay but of course you can't have a you
can't have a level spec
right
okay in relation to equations
with this we designed apply sides things
like that
so that was our way to avoid automatic
threadability in equations
yeah you're saying something like apply
sides f of
you know a plus b equals equals c
is that
um
which i think is useful i mean that's
more of an elementary math play
but definitely useful though okay let's
go back again to array reduce
um so i mean i i think we've got
yeah all right so okay so i'm still
trying to understand here
okay we've got array replicate all right
so the general i'm just sorry i'm just
trying to understand this the general
form here is array replicate
we think we have a um
i'm not sure if the name is quite right
but um
uh right and last time we were
discussing sort of a more
general syntax with a list of rules
absolutely yes absolutely that's correct
so this is
you know this left right insert after
and so on
right
okay so i think we've got array
replicate ready to do a trial
implementation
okay i think we even had here
yeah so we even had a a proposed syntax
here right it proposed
version oh we also had it possibly
called pad dimensions
but so sorry is that or i guess maybe
the second
okay so i'm not sure that these this
usage is unambiguous
though right because if i have something
of like three and i say
you know array replicate make the first
citizens three
three three three three three right so
this is why it we turned into last time
this top bottom one minus one et cetera
et cetera et cetera
this is specifying which th this is this
is the correct form
okay and we need to just get an
implementation of this so we know what
we're talking about here
okay we we had nailed down something
pretty good here which
which basically inserts into the levels
this is this works just like
insert works but it makes
these levels
it pads out those levels if that makes
sense
so in other words in the dimensions list
what this is doing is it's saying at
position one in the dimensions list
now have three five at position one in
the dimensions list
makes sense yep
um okay
so now now let's go back to what we
originally know and think i'm ready to
do array reduce
okay so let's take a look at array
reduce yeah
which is different from level applied
which i claim is going to be or level
mapped
which is i claim the more the the you
know a very useful
general thing okay so this is the
this is the explicit form of what will
otherwise become a headdress of
something like level applied
right guys yep
okay so again i
i claim that the first usage is just map
produces level and no it isn't because
no because
because what's happening here is like
subset
map this is um
um well reduces doesn't mean anything in
our language
so yeah i mean look at that look at the
example below
that's just doing map at level two this
in this case yes
level one or level one in this case
actually level one exactly
um yeah that's not useful yeah so
yes so what it is is actually i mean the
first use edge is a transpose
to put level n to be the last level
and then a map at level minus two
okay so but so so you're saying the
first usage is basically that
you know if you have an array a it's
transpose of map of transpose of a
that's the first usage uh there's not
two transpose just
one transpose to put the there are two
that's
not there because you've got to put it
back again no no well
not not in this case like like yeah it's
true that
well yeah there isn't necessarily a
transpose here i mean it depends what we
mean by transpose but that's
that's yeah putting the level n at level
minus one
with the last and then a map at level
minus two
and and you have your reduction for the
first case
and then for the over usage it's more
flattened
okay let's try to understand these
usages and then try to understand the
headdress form
the headdress form we basically we have
an array
let's say we want to say let's take this
example here
okay and let's look at the the headdress
form of this
and so we want to say level applied
of mean onto this
okay and what is that what does that
mean
that means that what we want to do is
take who
let's see mean normally
what does mean do ordinarily it means
work at a level
one right so you'd get uh
so mean will work at level zero right it
will take the whole expression
wow that's why well right but you have
to map it at level one
and you get as christopher was saying
the equivalent of the
reducer level right actually mean has a
convenient feature that it just does
what you want here
it does the column wise mean yeah which
is very useful
in uh right for standardization we're
just doing that i said and that's that
right okay so mean is a bad example mean
happens to work column wise by default
well not well i mean in this case you
can interpret it
as being column wise right but really
it's just adding the elements and
dividing by
n oh i see what you're saying okay
but actually it's just
adding the top level elements
using listability
yep right
okay so that's a pure coincidence
of the fact that you know plus stability
mean et cetera et cetera et cetera
so the more the more common case is
you say level applied of this and what
it's doing is
it's going to apply to columns and then
that's i mean that's not a question
there will be no argument
i i'm not sure i mean why would it be
column by default
i don't think that well it might be
level two by default we let's not worry
about that for a second oh yeah
i mean i think it would probably be
level two right column level two by
default but
this one i think level two but but i'm
not sure but anyway okay so let's say
it's this
okay so what that means is this is going
to say
this is going to turn into um
f of 1 6
list 1 6 11.
no a single single level of list
f of no actually it's the opposite i
mean check the example i
think it's the opposite it's it's
which example can you look on the early
use documentation
yes that's that's a positively bad case
because do we have an implementation
here can i actually run this
yeah if you do generally if you do
numeric array utilities backtick
reduce like i remove the the
and you probably have to do a get
general
utility hold on what do you want me to
do just get
numeric array utilities
it's a bit of a mouthful but utilities
yeah and uh exactly
and then you can actually with that you
can you should be able to use a reduce
but you don't which means you have a two
old version
i'm not running 12 2 here i don't think
i'm running 12 2 here so let me oh
that's why
12 2 head branch uh yep
why is the startup so slow can somebody
devin can you report this again yes
okay
all right so that i run this
okay now you say i can say array
releases
and it should work f of
you know this is a nice object let me
just so i'm not a confused about what
this actually
is let's do that and let's now say
array reduce f and now do i need another
argument or not
yes we need to say the axis that you
will reduce
on okay
okay that's just map in that case yes
okay i
don't think this is the right way around
it it is it is let's
take so explain it explain explain
explain so
the axis this is i think it's it's
squishing it in that access
exactly what what map does which is kind
of the opposite
i don't think it's the right way to say
it i think we should say at what level
it is going to do its operation
i mean the second one is not
reproducible with labels
with levels sorry it's some sort of
um them up pretty sure
right so this is the thing about
transposing it right so it's transposing
at level
you know it's transposing level uh one
in this case
to be level minus one and then it's
mapping exactly
at level minus two so
that's why it's kind of reducing this uh
i don't think this is going to be
understandable i think people are going
to think of this
as doing the operation
look this is the equivalent of taking
this thing okay
and saying you know
and doing this and saying all comma one
for example
right and then doing so that's in other
words
it's doing its thing and maybe array
reduces the right name but it's doing
its thing
at level two it's cycling over level two
i mean this is i think what the point of
the word reduce is is that you're
basically
you're getting rid of level one i think
that's what level are you getting rid of
i see i see i see which wow this is a
combination of map and transpose right
yeah but but another way to say it is
that what we're doing is we're saying
we're
yes we're going over all the indices
this is allifying every index
other than well this
this one is saying which indices to
alifi
in some sense is that correct and you're
going to reconstruct an
object from the other indices that
haven't been
reduced out i'd like to point out that
quotes qualifying is the same as
transposing
it's just a part one in the transpose
yeah sorry i think with the rank two we
can get confused there's only two levels
uh but i say rank three it's pretty nice
so it's really removing the
the you know the level that you indicate
if you have a matrix of size i mean an
array of size three by five by two
if you say a reduce at level two it will
remove
the the five okay so three by five by
two for example
okay yeah please if you do a reduce
of i don't know total doesn't matter
uh to be to be simpler total and then
level two the dimension is going to be
three
times two because the five is gone what
the hell happened there
i'll check the dimension but but what
did it do with this totals
i don't know what happened here okay can
you use f
right yeah that's not right
uh i don't know check the dimension
it has three levels so it cannot be
would you say
yeah oh yeah
i think there's an implementation bug
something wrong
which is weird maybe it's okay anyway
maybe it's uh
in the process of speeding up a reduce
something happen that's weird
okay well okay so that needs to fix but
but okay so you've got an example here
yeah
yeah exactly like this one actually the
same example that's weird
okay so this this this is saying
compute the standard deviation over the
second axis is that really over the
second
axis when you're reducing
what on earth does that mean i think the
problem here is that the standard
deviation is like mean
it does more things with vectors it has
a certain
so can we please not use the standard
deviation in the examples here
but that's that's the same i think if
you put f it worked i don't know why it
doesn't work on your own
that's weird okay something wrong going
going on but
that's what it should be for any of uh
hold on hold on so you're saying the
array
there i i can't i can't do these
if i'm supposed to do this arithmetic in
my head i can't do it if it was a's and
b's i might be able to see which one
went from which one
what is this doing now so this is taking
each pair
so i think i think the way to understand
this is first transpose the level you
are interested in to the
bottom and then map over it
yeah that's definitely one way and this
is how it's implemented all the way i
mean check the dimension
of the array three five two when i say
reduce
on axis 2 it means construct
3 by 2 vector of length 5
and and apply f on these vectors of
length 5. like is define all the vectors
to which the f is going to be applied
right i mean
i would think an alternative name for
this would be level apply or something
and then that if if this was called okay
let me just copy these things in there
just so we remember
what's going on if this was called
you know possibly or
level apply now i understand this map
this map thing is an issue but i mean if
we had level apply and level applied
the level applied is the headdress form
and level apply is the explicit form
well but i think right these are two
different things right
array reduces uh is a unary operation
whereas the london applied was
is for no no no that's not correct this
is the headdress form of this
this is a completely different thing
from the insertion stuff we were talking
about
that was level replicated oh okay yes
sorry i got
my names confused right so this is
this would be level applied so if we
said
you know to me it would make sense but
maybe it doesn't work
if we said level applied and maybe
you're telling me that this isn't the
way it can work
level applied of f comma 2 means
do column wise application
can that be made to work and then level
apply
level 2 means apply to level two
apply this operation to the
level two things
i mean that seems understandable to me
yeah for the matrix let's
let's see for maybe you're right but
let's see for an array of rank three
yes so in this case three by five by two
what would that do
i think that this thing
what it would do is it would treat it as
a triple of five by two objects
and then it would apply f onto the five
by two object
exactly so it's not on a vector so the
whole thing of this business of
prediction
you have a function that you give a list
of scalar as a vector
and it computes a number from that now i
understand that
i understand i understand that's one
thing you might want to do but that
requires going down
yeah that's a different thing i i know
but but is level applied
is a different thing it's uh it's it's
kind of
like you're going to do f on on arrays
not f on
vector so the question is the question
here is
does in array reduce
of f comma array does f
or lev spec
does f ultimately
get applied to
sub arrays or to
lists of scalars okay that's really the
the question of the default and that's
similar to this insertion business
where there are two different ways of
doing it right one is to go down from
the bottom
and the other is to go i'm sorry up from
the bottom or down from the top
what traditional the stability does is
go down from the top
am i making sense
right this reminds me a lot of the
situation with flatten
in which one can think of flattening one
level
and then but the denotation allows
flattening many levels at the same time
and also in the sense that flatten
internally contains a transpose
well here in my opinion the key
operation here
is transpose
yes so yeah it's a situation similar to
that and
same level of complication people having
problems understanding what
flattened us in the general case
right so sander is commenting and the
fact that it's diff
sorry just saying the fact that it's
different from map
and and all these other things is its
power is that you can do some operation
uh more simply than yes but you can't
achieve
column wise operations with map you
cannot so that's another
that's another thing yeah i think i
think right so one of the objectives
here is to make sure that columnized
operations are easy to do
so maybe there should be separate
conversations yeah
maybe there should be a column map and a
column apply or something
well we've thought about that we've
thought about that but but i mean i
think
um you know so that's i mean that would
just be the transpose of map of
transpose
because that's not what this is it's
it's turning out
yeah i mean you could generalize it more
about
you know if you have a tensor you know
if you want to apply it a
even deeper level but i'm not sure i
think even just doing columns
is a useful you know is a useful thing
yes
okay so comment from sandra on our live
stream if you have a five dimensional
thing
it is
let's see if you give so he's commenting
that i think this is supporting your
idea at en
that array reduce of level
n removes the nth index
and that's what you're proposing exactly
exactly
well the map is kind of specifying the
level that we keep
i mean all the equivalent of map and
well and this one is
specifying the level that you removed
okay i need to go to a different meeting
in a moment here but but um
notice that the removal is not performed
by array reduce itself it's
f which is responsible for removing
true so that's important thing because
you could have also mapping a function
that removes things
it will work
so stephen i've just put in
chat a simple function which i believe
is
what a uh
etienne is claiming array reduce does at
least for
the single level case um
and so then you can apply this to your
array of three five two and
etienne can tell us if that's what he
really means
yeah yeah i think okay so this
three five two here so this is simple
reduce
three five two oops f
three five two comma two although
actually i'm not sure it's this
anyway because you're switching
n and rank and i think it's not a switch
like
n should go at the end but the range
would stays well so this
is now a
a three by two thing that had the f
so i'm very confused here why is this
not
map at level two of f
mapper level two will keep the five
right the the point is that the level
two this is
applied at level two why does it not
apply at level two
because because you're keeping the two
as well right so you'd end up with
something of length
three because you'd wrap every five by
two matrix and an f
this is not doing that
so this is a combination
again it what it's doing is it's
basically it's it's another
weird way of thinking about it because
you're talking about the the allifying
right it's like array part
you just you map over okay you say array
part all comma
hash equals f of array part all comma
hash and you're just
mapping over all the indices and you're
changing the number of alls
right that's that's what this is doing
yeah so it's basically same thing but
the transpose is uh
like in that case it was working but the
true transpose is this one
it's uh you're not switching the last
one and n
you're just putting the n at the
end all right look let's
let's do the following okay the
we also want so do we understand the
headdress form of this thing
i think it's rather straightforward i
think it's basically just taking i think
it's just an argument
switcheroo on this and it's possible
even it's just the operating form of
this
i i think so the the only thing i'm
worried here is that we keep talking
about the levels while here this is all
shifted by one what the tn calls axis
one
is our level zero etc
so we should be careful with okay well
let's see
levels versus axes
question mark shifted by one
i have to go to a different meeting
about chemistry which actually is also
going to be live streamed
um so but we really need to
you know i think we're getting closer
here i would really like to follow this
up
perhaps later this week before we've all
forgotten how this works
um there was a question here on the live
stream about tensor notation and i'm
just wondering
can we write out what this is doing in
industrial tensor notation so to speak
or does it not have an analogous
operation there
i think i can do that i have to think a
bit about it but i think it's so
obviously the
transposition part you can't because
that's just super simple
so you can you just you just you know t
mu
u goes to t new mu or something right
right but i don't know about this
reduction how does he how do you do
reduction of a tensor
of an axis of a tensor so to speak it's
a mapping
so you just have to wrap f around the
tensor once
it has been transposed
yeah but then how do you d transpose
back again i mean in standard tensor
notation i'm talking about
and that that's the key that's the key
property
we were referring to before that the
function f is supposed to do something
it's supposed to convert vectors into
scalars if it does something else it
this is going to break
so i think we have to separate it's
going to break i mean is this going to
break or is it going to
it's not going to give the okay so this
this
imagine that imagine that it converts
vector vectors to vectors like
substitutions no i understand then it
would not be 3 2 anymore it will be
something different this form requires
that
f maps vectors to scalars
exactly well i i think in order to get
the dimensions to be exactly what you
say right
right it's not clear that that's what
you need yeah um
yeah the dimension identities
yeah actually we generalize it so i mean
we had this discussion before right
and we ended up you know the other usage
lines where you have uh
you can also instead of constructing
vectors you can also construct arrays
so it's it's a lot i mean the version
just after our classic but the last one
that's kind of the one we
alf came up with and uh with the help of
julio had a good idea of
to make that simpler anyway so it's
basically the same spec
as flattened and this con this defines a
bunch of arrays basically
so the spec before define a bunch of
vectors to which you apply f
this defines a bunch of arrays that you
apply f2
right right right so that's a generic
case i raised to a raised
and then it's flattening it's an it's a
generality of planning
yeah it's yeah same speaker's flattened
now
okay let's continue within a few days
here and let's see if we can nail this
down i think we're getting pretty close
um okay people on the live stream thank
you for your comments but we are now
going to a chemistry discussion
which will also be live streamed um
um okay